Cleopatra Rebel Moon I'm so curious
about that one
um I'm a big fan of Zacks and I I know
that that story idea was originally a
Star Wars pitch so can you maybe tease
you know what Star Wars fans or fans of
those types of movies will get from
Rebel moon but then also what is
something that makes it different and
stand out in terms of sci-fi fantasy
films
this is tough I saved the hardest
questions for last I real there's really
not much that I can say
um
but I will say that Zach is another
director that really enjoys what he does
he comes at it with such
enthusiasm he's camera operating he's in
the trenches with everyone
uh and it's a Fantastical world that
he's created I think people are gonna
really love the action the actors worked
extremely hard on the stunts and it it's
going to look really beautiful it's it's
gonna be epic that's all I can really
say I can't give it away